τη νομοθεσία ψηρίστηκε των τηλεφωνικών παρακολουθήσευ ν οποία ίσως είναι το μεγαλύτερον όπλο απέναντι στων
εξεχρονισμό το ορογανωμένο εκληματος αυτές οι συνομιλίες που θα μπορουν να πηγαίνουν μαρτυρία στο δικαστήριο
των μεγαλύτερον όπλο και επίσης να πω για την ποσότηζαν των αστυνομικώ και την παιότητα
που θα πρέπει να δουλεύει σε τιμήματα επιχείρησης και διερεύνησης η οποία πρέπει να ανεβεί
πωσοτικά ιδικά πρέπει να ανευει ο αρεθμόστων αστενομικώ το ρογανωμένο ενκλημα μπορεί να έχει τη
νύχτα τα εκαπένται υπαλληλούς και ια αντιμετώπισης από τη ν αστυνομία να έχω θέκα υπαλλήλο
στη νύχτα οπότα αντιλαμβάνεστε να λέεμε τα πράγματα με τον νόμα τους κύριας θησία σωστά
βία τα γήπεδα πίε στα κυριατεί γιατί αυτόν το πρόβλημα ακούμε διακόσι αστυνομική έαντάσπρομε ότι
ι δήποτε μπορέία σκεφτεή σε ένα κατεβάσει αστυνομία στο γήπεδο αλλά ένα δεισ ότι γίκοκπτα
που κλοφόρει να καταφέρουν να σουμιδενήσουν ότι επιχείρης υναίστησες γιατί εδώ και χρόνια αντί να
τρέχουμε με τις νομοθεσίες στα σωστές ενομίζει να με ότι κάθεφορά να πάνουμε στο ίπεδον
να κάουνε παιδίο μάχισ θέλουμε τη νομοθεσία για τα συφί τρόμε πολύ μπολέμο νεμίς σα
συντεχμία από τα σεφί γιατί λέμε την αλήθεια οι κυριότερη πιγή του χολικανισμό είναι οι
ανεξέλεκτη άνθρωποι μέσα στους σετέσμους φιλάνθρουν και είναι ξεκαθαρο θέλουμε τη νομοθεσία ν αυτή να
έρθει έλουμε των εξεχρονισμό της καρτασφυλάθλουν με λογισμικά και στα γύπεδα στης ισόδους μεκάμερες όλα
αυτά για να τρέχουμε με την παίννα των παραβάτη και όχι με τα πόδια κριοιών
ξέρεται ότι αυτή τη στυγμή του ποδόσφερο έχει κατομύρια λεφτά κάτω αυτά τ πράγματα που
ζητούμε ν νομοθεσίες ε μπορεί να πλαρωνώ να έχω τρακόσουν τα αστυνομικούς σκάσω σα εδοκυριακό
εμπορο αστερό τρακοσους αστυνομικούς που έξω που γζίνος που χρειάζονται τους αστυνομικούς σε διαρίξεις σε
προλίψεις για να μπορέσον να στνομεύψον έναν προδοσωερικόν αγόνα οποκι ο νόμος για την απόκρυψη
προσώπου που βρίσκεται στη βια στα γύπεδα αλλά όχι σε άλλες συναθρήσεις